so things are changing very fast for
weeks leaders in washington told us that
an american-backed no-fly zone in
ukraine would be unwise because it would
amount to an act of war against a
nuclear-armed russia as you can see
those views have evolved a lot
but in fairness congresswoman maria
salazar got there first salazar is a
longtime news anchor from miami who a
little over a year ago was elected to
congress as a republican she now sits on
the foreign affairs committee a week ago
a reporter from the gray zone asked
salazar what she thought of a no-fly
zone here's what she said
do you support a no-fly zone in ukraine
i've obsessed i support everything that
has to do with punishing vladimir putin
and helping the ukrainians wouldn't that
mean direct conventional warfare with
russia i don't know what it will mean
but you know freedom is not free so you
don't know what a no-fly zone will mean
if you have to shoot down russian planes
i mean of course
i don't know what it will mean but you
know freedom is not free now we made fun
of that answer last week when we first
showed you that clip but now what we
mocked is the consensus in washington we
don't know what's going to happen we've
got to do it immediately that's the
argument you're hearing
at this point no one wants to say it out
loud but it is true at this point a
shooting war with russia seems
inevitable how could war with russia not
be inevitable virtually everyone with
power is for it
we remain against it we think that
joining a war in eastern europe will
hurt this country though to be clear
when and if that war starts we will be
praying passionately for america's total
victory
unlike so many in the foreign policy
establishment we love this country above
all and we mean it
but in the meantime while the united
states is still technically at peace we
thought it'd be worth asking people who
are calling for war if they have
considered in detail what a war would
mean for this country congresswoman
maria salazar was gracious enough to
accept our invitation to come on the
show we're grateful she did she joins us
tonight congresswoman thanks so much for
coming on um
thank you for inviting me well yes so
since you have called for war with
russia
how do you think that war once it begins
would play out
i think that's a hypothetical
hypothetical question i think that we
should concentrate tucker in what uh
zelinski asked congress today
i'm sorry i i'm sorry i can't no and i'm
and i'm in no way
um trying to cut you off i but i can't
let you a lot over that you said we
should shoot down russian planes that's
of course war
since you've called for that anywhere a
member of congress i think
well you just said on the tape replay
that was taken yeah but that was taken
out of context because i said of course
that i know what that means
i was that that that interview was not
very well conducted and that's why i'm
here because i want to clarify my
position
and my position is
that we should not take not the no-fly
zone off the table but before that
that's two we need to do one and one is
to give zelinski exactly what he's
asking for no troops on the ground let's
give him the mix and the s-300 what he
needs to defend his own air
airspace so he will create his no his
own no-fly zone and that's what i think
we should have done months ago it's
embarrassing that this guy this
president who is under the bullets has
come to congress to beg for us to give
him something that we should have done a
long time ago okay
let me be clear when you say we should
give president zelinski what he's asking
for he demanded today i think you were
there that the united states enforced
the no-fly zone which you so you are for
denying him that
well but he also said and then we can
give you alternatives so since we know
that that should not be taken off the
table and i repeat it i do believe that
we should go to plan a
which is to give them all the military
weapons that he's asking for because i
think a lot of people sympathize with
that let me just say i think a lot of
people who saw president zielinski
speech and today and who've seen the
atrocities in ukraine
feel deep sympathy for the ukrainian
people and want this to end i'm
certainly among them
but i'm wondering i am
okay
and everywhere especially for the us
government or one of its elected
representatives act on behalf of the
core interests of the united states
government it's really super simple so
if the united states is provided let me
just tell you let me
if the united states is providing
weapons to one side in a war
how is that not participating in the war
listen now do let me just backtrack and
say that you say that we're supposed to
be representing the american people i
represent district number 27 where you
have millions of cuban americans and i'm
representing what we think we know that
we we acquired peace through strength
look at what happened in 1960 fidel
castro and jfk i'm sorry okay i can't i
can't i'm not gonna i'm sorry i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna take the
anti-communist lecture from anybody
because of course i agree with you or no
no
i hope that you're not speaking for
quote cuban americans but for all
americans because it's not a racial
question it's a question of talking
about national action i'm representing
district number 27. i understand what
i'm just saying right and i'm as against
communism i think as anybody but my
question is if we are providing weapons
to one side in a war i think it's fair
to ask maybe the other side would say
that's an act of war against us
and if that happens then what next and
to not think about that seems negligent
but since you're on the foreign affairs
committee i know that you have thought
it through so tell me your views on what
would happen next
tucker we have been providing javelins
and stingers and ammunition and we're
providing a lot of military armament so
what is the difference between that and
the migs and the s-300s what's the
difference i mean
you have to understand that we are
unfortunately the united states has
fallen into the vladimir putin's trap he
is the one dictating what we're gonna do
what we're not gonna do he said we do
not want we are imposing a no-fly zone
over ukraine and we're so we're letting
people control our behavior okay so that
seems like that seems like a loss right
there right okay but let me just ask you
because we believe we don't need to have
more evidence that putin has bad intent
that he's evil a lot of people believe
he's crazy including some informed
people including many russians so we
know he's volatile
and we know that he's heavily how many
nuclear weapons by the way does russia
have do you know
many
many about six thousand that's the guess
one isn't that and that's a fair that's
a fair is enough so are we concerned at
all
that
he might use a nuclear weapon against
the united states is that a concern is
that something that you consider as you
recommend these of policies of course
we're
of course that we're very concerned and
we're also concerned that he may be
throwing a biological weapon against the
ukrainians within the next few hours
because he cannot take kiev or kiev as
he thought he was going to so of course
that we are and uh and confronting a
dictator anybody but i think that we
should put this into context and i thank
you very much for giving me the
opportunity of course if we believe in
the free world that this is just going
to be the first or the last
confrontation with a bad actor we're in
for a very big surprise because if we do
not confront bad actors with strength
then we're going to have china and
russia and iran and fidel and you and
venezuela okay
but but if and needless to say i've made
that argument you know for 30 years on
television the question is are we doing
it with all available risks known to the
population in whose name we're doing it
so i'm asking you what do you think the
chances are and i'm sure you've gained
this out as a member of the foreign
affairs committee that putin uses
nuclear weapon against the united states
in response to this what would you
calculate the chance he can
sure that we are taking that into
consideration but what do you think i
mean our viewers are i'm sure supporting
you i think most conservatives are on
your side and but i just think they
should know
what the informed view of the likelihood
of a retaliatory retaliatory nuclear
strike from vladimir putin is what do
what what would you assess it as being
and i repeat that's a hypothetical
question and i'm totally hypothetical
that he will not he will not take that
step if starting today the biden
administration will send the message
that we are in charge the nato is ready
to confront him and so are we and that
is the problem that i believe i'm not
sure if you share in my view that you
obtain peace
you contain this you can you can uh then
destin
take the they take the all the power
away from putin if you show strength
okay so do you believe that do you
believe do you believe that's true so
president zelinski said yesterday
that he is considering declaring that
ukraine would not join nato
in
exchange for having russian truth
withdraw from his country would you
describe this is president zielinski
speaking would you describe that
zelinski can
who am i to say what's correct and what
would you accept would you well i don't
know you
is that
is that would that be an answer you'd be
satisfied with if zolensky made good on
what he just suggested that we'll agree
to neutrality will relinquish claims to
crimea and the russians
leave
would that be okay with you would you
consider that an honorable exit or would
you consider it a display of weakness
if zelinski comes to the united states
congress and he says that this is the
best path forward we are no one to say
something to the contrary but i don't
think he's going to say that so we're
we're creating scenarios here that are
hypothetical
you may not be following this closely
but he has said that multiple times so
of course that i understand and i have
that would spare the deaths
okay but that would spare the deaths and
since i know you have great concern for
the civilian population of ukraine that
would spare the deaths we all do of
untold thousands and preserve the
capital city from being destroyed so
would that be better
than
increasing the level of armed conflict
in ukraine which would be a better
outcome that's for the ukrainians what
do you mean you're you're you're an
american policy maker who's imposing
your views on ukraine and i'm asking you
simply would that be
why not why not push
let me well of course you are you're
saying we need to send
material billions of dollars arm the
military and i'm not criticizing your
position i'm just asking you has it
occurred that many lives might be saved
if we were to encourage
the the peaceful solution that's already
on the table
are you doing anything
in that direction
if the ukrainians want to go that route
they have the right to and we are no one
to say anything about it because they
are the ones dying on the streets and
they're the only ones they certainly are
they certainly are dying that's right i
don't know notice any members of
congress or david frum laying down their
lives since the ukrainians but have you
have you suggested that
tucker i think that we have uh
we have talked about this point enough i
also wanted you to give me the
opportunity to explain to you i want to
import you because you said that i was
for in favor of open borders and i
wanted to i talked to you well you just
called last month for the amnesty for
tens of millions of people who came into
this country illegally
because i read the legislation no i did
not actually about 20 minutes ago
okay i'm glad you did and i will invite
you to read it again because let me just
give me 30 seconds and i promise i'll
give it to you in sound bites
the dignity act which i presented last
month is an immigration reform law
probably the first one that the gop has
presented in a long time
it has one of the strongest border
security measures in the history of the
united states congress right got it but
but it also provides something right
amnesty amnesty is what we have now
tucker amnesty is when you have more
than 30 million illegals listen to me
without paying for schools for roads or
for hospitals i am giving them dignity
so they can start paying and they can
now we're getting pretty deep into the
talking points
people who came over our border without
permission
are not being punished they are instead
being rewarded and so you know they're
not let me let me answer to that very
different standard to ukraine i'm
wondering if russians fleeing putin do
you believe should be allowed to start
new and better lives in ukraine and i
bet you'd say no because you believe in
ukrainian nationalism but not america i
want to be rigorous i'm talking about
those people who have lived lived here
for more than five years
that have not committed a crime that
have american children and who are
contributing to our economy i want to
give them something called dignity and
then redemption i'm not talking about
path to citizenship i'm not talking
about amnesty i'm talking about no no
but let me no i'm not and i don't want
you to misrepresent what we did and we
worked for one whole year so we can
solve just because then let me ask you
let me ask you
our viewers
you're for sending migs the fact that
you agree with me does that mean that
you have to misrepresent what's on the
bill well our look i think you've said
it yourself that people who came here
illegally tens of millions of them would
be allowed to stay they would not be
punished they would be rewarded now you
think that's enhancing their dignity by
the way i'm not against those people i
just can't help notice the contrast
between your desire to send migs to
ukraine to preserve its borders but not
here should we send the us military to
the mexican border since you have
admitted that tens of millions of people
have come here illegally that our
borders are poorest they're not defended
they are open
should we send the u.s military to the
mexican border
that is what i have created a whole plan
so we can really seal the border because
you know what would you my community
would you call it then let me finish let
me see
the one that i represent okay listen
i am let me finish give me 15 seconds i
shall i have thank you
i have created a series of measures so
we can secure the border because we the
browns the hispanics the latinos in this
country are not in favor of open borders
the problem is that no one asks us
we want to live in the promised land and
we want to contribute because you know
very well that if we deport those 11 or
13 million we may not have food by
friday why because let me okay
please and i'm sorry i let you i i think
everyone understands this that we have
other supply chain issues and by the way
i'm not attacking anybody living in this
country legally or illegally i'm asking
questions about borders
all of us are appalled by the violation
of ukraine's borders
you don't seem as appalled by the
violation of our borders by tens of
millions of people so let me ask you for
the third time sure
military representation okay then would
you support the u.s military
securing the united states border
tonight or on the same timetable as
sending migs to ukraine how about that
uh that's hypothetical again no it's a
very straightforward question
what do you mean just say it you're not
and you're reporting but not here
you're giving me the the first the whole
segment which is great and i thank you
very much let's get back to my bill i
don't want to miss i am correct
you're not you don't support sending the
us military to the border you don't i
just want our viewers to understand that
you're for defending a foreign country
but not our own and i think it's pretty
clear i am supporting it for
all the technology we could find so we
can secure the border we are we're all
the military the veterans the police
forces that we could hire so we can
secure and seal the border not only for
people but fentanyl and child sex
traffickers so i just told you the bill
is right there it's there's technology
it's not so simple as to say you're
gonna put this or that it's a series of
of technicalities a series of
technologies i get it i get it that is
for the border all right i agree with
your intent you know if you're screening
the border i'm totally on your side and
thank you for that what are you going to
do but let me ask you this let me just
ask you a question can you see why
americans who support the ukrainians
right to secure their own borders i mean
i certainly do most people do all
americans do can you see the frustration
that they might feel listening to you a
lawmaker say yeah there's a process but
when it happens in a foreign country we
have to send billions of the u.s
military your sons
but we can't kind of do that here
because why i mean can you sort of
understand the frustration a little bit
but i have never said that i want to
send
troops our boys to fight in ukraine
and we're standing at the same time
stingers and javelins and ammunitions
and we're sending a lot
you're misrepresenting this bill that is
probably one of the best bills that has
been presented when it talks about
immigration reform law i invite you to
read it and invite me back so we can
discuss it
all right congresswoman i don't agree
with you but i certainly appreciate your
coming on it's hard to get people to do
that and i
and uh and i appreciate that you did
thanks of course invite me again so we
can continue talking about immigration
which is one of the biggest problems we
have and if the gop doesn't realize it
we will never win another election again
yeah you could actually i think hispanic
voters are trending republican because
they're for borders
that you are not providing right no it's
not true once again is representing true
thanks so much good to see you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else